the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the St
Louis chess club and Scholastic Center
I'm Yasser I'm with Vega Vega we're
gonna have some fun today
we are bringing you the summer chess
Classics two tournaments and they are
both been very enjoyable we're round
three yes let's take a look at the
standings Bingham after two rounds in
group a in group a after two rounds
Benjamin bulk and John Burke are leading
the tournament and no one has a perfect
score already it indicates the
tournament is
strong and the three people are leading
the tournaments with one and a half
points and others have one point and ABI
money mission hasn't scored any points
yet
is struggling so far exactly and our B
group uh what's happening
they are playing a great uh tournament
and they score two and a out of two and
they're leading the tournament and
behind them Brandon Jacobson and Andrea
Hong was one and a half points and we
have a one player look at the Salvage
who hasn't scored any points yet too and
tell us about the format for these two
tournaments format of the tournament is
10 player round robin events A and B 90
minutes for the first 40 moves 30
minutes for the rest of the game with 30
seconds increment throughout the game
yeah and we have a pretty
straightforward schedule absolutely we
have games every day until August 10th
and May maybe if it's necessary we'll
have playoffs as well ah very nice and
tell us about the pairings do the honors
and the pairings for this round three
round three pairings are great and we
have a key matchup book versus here they
have been uh like teammates for a while
right so it's a very interesting matchup
because they know each other and also
they are very strong chess players yes
they are indeed as we take a look at the
two they're playing the chase just a
little bit down the street and we see
darush on the blacksided position really
intensely looking and let's take a look
at the game as I bring it up on my
screen a key moment occurred early in
the opening right here I think a lot of
players are inclined in such positions
to play Rook to E1 men are saying E4
even the potential move Queen D3 with E4
uh Benjamin took a different
approach he played the move Knight D2
with a very clear idea wants to play E4
however this has one key drawback the
pawn on D4 is not protected neither by
the Knight nor by the queen and this
allowed darush to play the move B5 now
the desirable E4 has a problem oops
we're blundering the D4 Pawn we can't do
that so after the move B5 came capture
capture Knight captures Queen B6 and
essentially the whole operation with
Knight D2 in my opinion kind of
boomerang because basically black got
rid of his b-pawn weak or otherwise for
I think a pretty strong D for d-pawn but
that's not the end of the story The the
next part of the story is if we can get
an E4 and you know a little Ambush that
would be okay and we now are caught up
with the players also it seems like
tarish playing fast and then his spent
all his time in couple of moves already
which is very interesting yes and also
both the players are known to be very
slow yeah Benjamin bulk he always has
some trouble and parishes as well as
well uh two twins if you will I like it
yeah with very similar style right with
the time trouble now the position gets
very very interesting and complex after
D5 D4 because there is the move E4 E5
on Tap White will probably want to move
his Knight first did the move E5 is
going to cause uh some distress
but before we get too deeply involved in
this game tell us about the pairings for
Group B uh Group B pairings are great
for the all of the matches is going to
be great for sure and we already have
some results look at the Salvage and
Alexander Linderman they had a fast draw
as well as elf Shan versus a Semion they
decided to end the games with repetition
absolutely and our Marquee matchup will
be our key matchup today is Jacobson
versus Chandra who is akshat is leading
the tournament and Jacobson is right
behind him it's a very important for
settings absolutely you bet well let's
jump right into that game as well so
this uh as you can see kind of came from
a Carlsbad Queens Gambit decline uh
pieces got traded on F4 should say
Bishops white grabbed a bit of space
over here on the queen side h7h6 and I
thought this move uh I found this move
interesting of a little bit perplexing
I was thinking that when you have your
Pawn on D4 your Outpost your natural
Outpost or E5 as well as C5 so I thought
I I would have lost a good wager that
white would want to have
bring his Knight to D3 so he could jump
uh especially to the square E5 instead
Brandon went for Bishop H3 when you play
the move Bishop H3
because they are mine if you want to
play G5
it's weird I wouldn't even understand if
King was on C8 but like yes exactly uh I
guess the idea is that he just feels no
this is intriguing Knight E6
um
he wants to attack his six pound that's
the whole idea well there may not be an
E6 Pawn Rook uh to G1 I think we are
just now catching up with the players
yes and we we have it so clearly White's
agenda is straightforward he wants to
play the move G5 Black's agenda is
equally as straightforward he wants to
play E5 so let's have a look see so what
happens after E5 I'm assuming it feels
like G5 yeah that's everything all in
yeah kind of thing so if you take on a
G5 most probably I'll take on E5 and
take with the Rook on G5 ah very good
it looks a little strange right okay but
there there is a pot of gold at the end
of the rainbow right you've opened up
the Rook I have to go to uh not the most
attractive Square I feel like I'm being
a little bit beaten backwards here I've
got this little check so good thing is
that I cannot take on it yeah exactly is
fine yeah you're ready to grab uh okay
so we think that E5 and G5 uh that there
are moves that I can make I should have
made him move just now did he let me
just refresh my my board for a moment
yeah I was about to say
one of the things
and I think this is a really really
important
concept to have in mind imagine
that there's a flank King side Queen
side doesn't matter there's a flag and
the Palms are storming towards you on
the flank King side Queen side one of
the best ways to avoid a pond storm and
the Damage it can cause get your pieces
out of the way yeah exactly so in this
particular case uh akshat played the
move Knight D7 and what's the idea one
of the ideas rather behind the move is
that after a move like G5 you can buy
simple H5 and then he's stopping all the
counter play of his opponent yeah it's
not simple simple yeah I think that's
one of the concepts there but still
night can come to F4 creating some
tension there but the problem is Knight
D7 could be that H5 and G5 is coming
actually H5 and G5 for white
let's give a look uh at H5 and I love
active pieces so let's go active you're
going to go active at two I guess and in
this particular case
um I'm not really worried about G6 if I
can get in E5 then oh but here this is
what I would be afraid of yes anything
where I get my Bishop very
I don't like that you'd love to bury the
bishop
absolutely yeah exactly uh okay hold on
I'm being a little bit too flippant here
yeah I think after H5 you you have to
play Bishop F7 the idea is after G5 you
need to take on H5 so if you shouldn't
be on H3 indeed but hold on but here the
bishop looks a little forlorn doesn't it
like I go here and then I go well
you're right by the way my Bishop
doesn't belong on on age
three but I do have Bishop like a a kind
of a billiard shot I think that was
actually Brandon's idea so he won't
exchange the Bishops he played Bishop H3
H3 to trick his opponent and save the
bishop instead of knights
might be the idea let's just take a
quick Gander at the two games that were
agreed to a draw
ah but before we go to the games that
we're drawn these players are fighting
they're fighting hard what are they
fighting for they're fighting for uh
great prices here group a is first place
is six thousand dollars second place is
four thousand and third place is three
thousand dollars and from fourth to tens
they still get a good amount of price
there right and then total price font of
the tournament is twenty two thousand
dollars nice and the price man for Group
B Group B first prize is four thousand
dollars second prize is two and a half
and third prize is two thousand dollars
and the rest of the players also get
some prizes here and with the total
price fund of Thirteen thousand dollars
fourteen thousand dollars per thing
nice I like it yeah I love it uh let's
jump to the game of elshon and samyan
they've already finished they that game
was a draw as you can see at the playing
Hall a couple of the tables are empty
and uh this one ended in a Perpetual
after an intriguing opening I did
so much of the opening play is theory
that I'm not completely sure where we
stopped I have seen this position before
me too okay and in fact I have seen this
position before after the move 96. I
think it's very intriguing that black is
neither interested in capturing on D3 or
capturing on B3 but rather saying to
White okay I want to have my phone right
and how are you going to win it back
well got to develop bring the pieces
over as Bishop D2 Rook on D1 is on
White's agenda
and again
the the play to my way of thinking has
actually been pretty natural so I'm I'm
again thinking that this is pretty there
pretty theoretical when I see a move
like D3 absolutely you just know they
know yeah it's on there it's it it's in
their prep so we get to this position
and then I find the move h2h4 intriguing
so again it looks like real prep because
it's sort of like saying go ahead
take my palm
so that we will have a bishops of
opposite color position where I'll get
you know some really nice control of
dark squares and I think I can even take
on H4 and play Bishop B4 and exactly
and you have an initiative whether or
not you have an advantage I'm confused
uh that did not happen after H4 which by
the way also Intimates that I'm ready to
play Knight G5 on a good day H6 and
guess what comes now
E6 very forcing very fortunate that's
what happens when you start leading the
tournament they will find ways of not
giving you any chance any chances
whatsoever white sacrifice is a rook for
this perpetual and that's exactly what
happened and also we have a result in
group a Nicholas Theodore just defeated
wow okay that is the best very
surprising yeah
it happened very fast and exactly
Nicholas won with the black pieces
um Advanced French defense with E5 which
by the way in my opinion that when
somebody plays the the French defense
Knight C3 Knight D2 is fine but to my
way of thinking the single most
challenging move is the advance E5 I'm
glad to hear that yes sir I play E5 okay
well among users it shows you courage
your understanding yeah
pigs takes and the players uh quickly
get into their prep including F7 F6
takes a well-known position right and
foreign exists
I wonder what ronak did wrong well so
far so far he already did something
wrong right Bishop is on F5
it should have a very good Bishop which
is a a very nice surprise for for for
black uh always when I get into these
positions I must say I'm very a keenly
attuned and I'm always sensitive to
these exchange sacrifices here it
doesn't work but you just have to make
sure it doesn't work 22 Queen B6 B3
Bishop Knight okay so let's see you want
to you want to get rid of this uh Bishop
by the way for one Pawn black has the
two Bishops and what looks to me to be
very easy uh play F3
Bishop back okay
I have a feeling wrong at blunt or
something there's no way to lose this
game so fast
well there goes an exchange right okay
not so bad uh F4 oh F4 pardon me Rook
takes I apologize it's not working not
C4 I think the whole idea was The Rook
D5 was wrong
possibly yeah yeah because B5 is exactly
coming and you cannot hold your Knights
good squares right I don't have you have
enough I don't think you have enough
compensation for this all uh Queen A2
that feels also a little bit oh yes uh
isn't it time to bring we always thought
of the first rank as a kind of Barracks
so that's where your pieces your chest
is again between two opposing armies so
at the start of the game your your your
pieces are in their barracks and you've
got to bring them into battle so
whenever we see a knight on E1 we kind
of say well it's in its Barrack it's
sleeping and uh it has to work and you
got to bring it out now I'm not saying
that Knights F3 would have saved the
game or anything like that but just feel
that uh we're we're we're we're
playing some somebody's down oh my God
oh there it goes
no it's smooth and clean Victory by Nick
it's a very good game it's a very good
membership if life was a great idea yeah
exactly let's quickly go to the game
between alien
Billy you might have Nick
to tell us how uh they did how he
thought the game went but we're
impressed Mishra our U.S junior Champion
starting zero finally he's scored it's
important to score exactly no matter
what uh slav defense
and
again I always thought that this is kind
of funny you know you you played the
move C6 and then you go C5 it's like you
stagger yeah forward uh the reason that
you can get away with this is because
the Knight is on uh D2 so as the game
continued C5 Bishop B2 B6
uh Bishop B7 F4 94.
trade trade oh after this move F7 F5 the
positions completely blocked this is
oh this is how they got it Rook F7 so we
have to understand why Bishop takes
is impossible
Rook D1 and the players quickly
okay uh quickly ended up in a an evenish
ending just going through the game
between Ilya and Mishra
and it's one of those games that nothing
really really happened Nicholas
congratulations welcome to the show
thank you absolutely yeah of course of
course
the French defense yay yeah it was my
childhood opening yeah it's been
probably 13 years since they last played
in classical at least so you're going
back to a a favorite uh begum was here
and I said that for me whenever you're
playing the French one of the most
challenging if the if not the most
challenging is the advance E5 V5 e45
sorry definitely it's very topical
nowadays exactly I was expecting three
Knight C3 right
um which is and then you have your
choice the the classical steinettes with
Knight F6 or the winner and there's two
very different
um styles there uh what's your
preference against Knight C3 do you like
the winner or the classes I don't want
to reveal them
very good E5 C5 uh tell us when your
preparation more or less stopped and and
now this is all standard right yeah I
mean I I knew
um this is what's best plan with Bishop
D3 to right damager damage black spawn
structure exactly and yeah after he
takes their
three or four popular moves here okay
the main one is rookie one I guess
but there's like green D3 rookie one is
the main move yeah I think there's even
some Blitz game otherwise against Magnus
yeah some titles you say
um but yeah Queen D3 I vaguely called F4
is an idea but I wasn't sure if it's
exactly at this point
well it made the the whole game makes
this really nice impression on us so
you know oftentimes you know we we do
The annotation by result U1 therefore F4
is a good move right but it did work out
really nicely right yeah I mean I I
thought I was
um putting pressure during the game
absolutely uh our cursory glance that we
had we got to this position yeah
actually here I spent a bunch of time
trying to figure out if I need to go
Bishop B4 first or queen B6 right and I
wasn't exactly sure exactly
uh always I was saying to begum too that
I'm always cognizant whenever we get to
these types of positions of these Rook
sacrifices you have to be be you know
your spidey sense has to tingle and make
sure that you never uh allowing that the
queen B6 okay uh
looks very natural right I mean you're
putting pressure on the B Pawn if he
moves the Knight well now your Bishop E4
comes even with more uh Force so B3 and
tell me when you think he made a mistake
because again everything
has a smooth quality I was sort of
expecting uh 91 Rook D1 okay actually
there was a nice attack please
I mean it's pretty basic but if he plays
Knight D3 here which is sort of
desirable too yes to get out of his
piece a little bit Yeah I have 95. okay
he can't take with a knight so it's
clear because C2 is hanging C5 and now I
thought I have Rook take C2 oh
uh-oh uh-oh Queen takes C2 and now Queen
G6
double attack isn't it yeah that that
that's pretty uh
uh from side to side and uh yes but it's
easy to get lost
um in all of these variations during the
game yeah that's why I was spending so
much time exactly Queen A6
um well at this point uh it feels like
again
you're just going forwards whites on the
back foot F2 F3 yeah I completely
underestimated these three Source
because I did I thought I could just
take on C2 and then take on A2 but right
it doesn't exactly work out for me
because you win your final back life is
good but yeah you won right Queen takes
B3 Rook fb1 okay Queen C4 93 and I can't
defend my queen and especially four and
actually Four
guarding yeah yeah this is not you you
you got caught with your hand in the
cookie jar in this case yeah there was
also another important line so after
rookie one yeah
I could try Bishop B4 okay it doesn't
work because of Queen G5
a moment ago you a checkmated on G2 now
you're suffering now he's checkmating
you on G7 okay so that okay so you're
not winning your Pawn back right away
but you you just played the position as
if you had sacrificed and now it's up to
White and it but it's also pretty funny
like Bishop G6 yes he wasn't really
threatening to take my Bishop so
I don't know if I had to retreat or ah
you mean uh the move F3 doesn't come
with the thread yeah because F1 is
hanging to the queen and the Rook
but okay he's gonna play 93 so you go
back
um where did it go wrong for him because
this is just yeah at this point I
thought it was already winning pretty
much but he only had 10 minutes to make
20 months so that was the difficulty
time Factor he was also trying to play
very fast to put pressure exactly and I
I did feel the pressure yeah yeah the
ticking clock uh here I mean it besides
you know just there's also push and push
too so for example if I would play G3 in
order to be able to play Knight in F4
maybe this no ah or even Queen B6 first
yeah oh does that work too that was a
whole idea of 92 was just a kid yeah I
mean even Bishop E4 could be a move oh
man that's really nasty
yeah it's
it's the it's it's not happiness
I'm not uh those two Bishops in the open
position in the game he took the pawn
with the idea that I suppose he wanted
to play F4 and somehow two pawns but he
never had the timing right F4 rookie
five right yeah I mean I was expecting
him to select the exchange there's no
other way he can untangle yeah 94 makes
sense to defend E5 yeah and A4 to
prevent B5 and I mean again it's like a
Tempo all we want you is trying to play
F4 you can get an F4 maybe he has a
playable position
but uh well at this point it kind of
becomes a conversion one final question
for you is here I wasn't impressed by
the queen A2 move and I was you know
okay I'm not thrilled I don't but at
least shouldn't he played Knight F3 with
ideas I thought I would play Rook D3
here Rook to D3
F4 yeah so Queen B4 right
is it just A3 I think so and then yeah
just A3 and 935 Queen D5 exactly you're
just hanging at that
Nicholas congratulations very very nice
how do you like the tournament how do
you like St Louis everything good I mean
I've been in St Louis for the last five
years because of this Lou yeah yeah the
tournament has been great so far right
I'll try to keep it up yeah I guess in
the next round all right well good luck
in the next round thank you absolutely
and as we go uh back to our tournament
games I'm gonna just bring up the game
of pranav and
Sassy this kind of all Indian Derby and
it is a mess I don't know this comes
from a rui Lopez
B1 why would you play Rook B1 that is a
confusing confounding move Knight C5
Knight F3 Queenie you will oh well thank
you baby because I am the question why
okay I'll play Rook B1 exactly so it's
sort of like again begum and welcome
back by the way great to interview thank
you
um
uh strategically right you know you've
got good pieces I've got bad pieces I'm
going to exchange my bad pieces for real
good pieces
where our Rooks are opposed on the open
file I don't want to see to you the open
file I'm going to trade Rooks but Prana
it feels very unnatural to play Rook B1
but there's a line that's I cannot like
like show the whole line right now it's
just the opening line when you have to
actually not to take on the A8 but play
Rook B1 and B3 or B4 and try to attack
B5 Pawn actually so what uh pranav is
doing is to trying to create more play
and then put pressure on B5 Pawn or B5
line and then he is trying to use Knight
on bisaman that it's not really well
well let's see what happens because I
think uh Knight C5 sassy is like saying
hey I'm kinda kind of sided suddenly my
Rook is going to invade along the
seconds because I'm very excited about
this match because there was Indians and
then a different Generations exactly so
I'm glad that Emperor nav is trying to
fight and find new ideas like this
exactly Queen B6 uh nothing wrong with
Queen B6 everything's fine uh just like
looking at this position and you know to
my way of thinking
um
I
would play two moves here the the first
two moves that come to my mind uh first
one D5 with the idea that you are more
or less going to play E5 I'm going to
sacrifice a pawn for the two Bishops and
the idea yeah I love the two Bishops I
think it was because I was really
strongly influenced by Bobby Fischer so
Bobby Fischer had a book and it was our
Bible it was the 60 memorable games and
he said in the book you know you can win
an exchange and we all understood what
that meant we could win a rook for a
bishop or a minor piece for a major
piece a rook but he also said you could
win the minor exchange it's like
it's like a minor example and that's the
two Bishops so he felt that winning the
two Bishops was so good it even deserved
this appellation of the minor exchanges
or like okay that that fixed itself in
my mind that hey this is a really good
thing and you're going to get really
good compensation so that's the first
one that comes to my mind the second is
just as you said you got to get you you
you gave up the the second rank
so that you could play B3 or B5 uh your
choice thank you very much I'll take
your second right I know you'll love it
too I'll put the Rook there and then you
can decide what you wanted
it has a huge problem right okay too
because I don't it's it's not I don't
know oh no you don't have and then Rook
B1 is kind of already holding B2 pawn
and then now I can play G5 so that's why
he's playing Queen P6 to avoid the pin
exactly so you're welcome to play G5 and
that and I'll post up my rule you you
limit you're just trying to annoy yeah
I'm there I'm there I'm taking away Rook
pardon me I'm taking away the move B4
let's see what happened Queen V6 G5 tags
takes D5 okay another way of applying
your ideas yeah well another way of
trying to give up a pawn in this case
Bishop F6 GFC I will give up a pawn for
the two Bishop and the H3 is hanging as
well and 94 Bishop
and we've
Claire's I believe so just checking uh
there you have uh Sassy's uh he's so
confused he's like what is this kid
doing B1 and G5 hanging yeah pawn and
trying to play Just V3 shall we uh I
mean
I will nibble Bishop oops excuse me I
think I I did something with the mouse
there I would nibble here let's have a
look shall we Bishop takes H3 okay go
ahead and kill me okay let me think
Queen H5
D Queen H5 is a is a delicious
delicious and I'm trying to play F3 and
then just made you
I appreciate
well can I suck no I cannot
so in this particular I was thinking of
Bishop Knight E4 and then takes a rookie
four and Bishop before G6 just go back
then I I don't have anything let's just
say that after F3 I have this wishes I
have that uh
do you use the term swishing Zug or in
between move in between more I do
understand like probably
Americans American chess players use the
German terms
because we get this tactical books you
know and they say yeah learn the switch
I'm not a fantasy person too okay how
are you gonna kill me you weren't gonna
you were gonna take on e4 right
it's going to take on e4 you're going to
take with the Rook no oh sorry I changed
my mind
it's not working yeah sir well I was
gonna show you show them why did your
idea not work
because you did want to play Rook takes
E4 and it looked very uh attractive the
moment you suggested it because it takes
takes again there's this move G6 yeah
that's the problem I want to have my
Rook on E1 even after G6 so I can play
Rook E3 and
so something like this and but no I'm
not on time and then Bishop on G7 is
like perfect correct like yeah I cannot
never meet you exactly let me just
refresh my board by the way we have
another result another draw between John
Burke
yeah yeah the the the they are teammates
as well by the way yeah they went to
Webster and then they were teammates and
John Burke graduated and Oram is
graduating next semester I believe very
nice uh in this position besides the
move Bishop takes H3 that does invite
Queen H5 we see that Sassy is thinking
very very carefully I think he's
confused more than anything he's like
trying to find what's the trick
yeah exactly right there and there's got
to be lots of Tricks going on here
um these kids are kind of scared to play
yes yeah again they're like they they're
very resourceful so I think he's just
being careful I'm actually wondering can
I play Bishop H3 I don't try to mate you
I'll just like beat me or something
Bishop takes h3b3 I agreed uh we'll go
there in just a second I'm just thinking
to myself okay so I see
I really respect him uh greatly I think
he's a fantastic player and the fact
that he doesn't snap right away on H3 is
convincing to me that he's looking at
alternative plans so I'm looking at this
position I'm saying well what could
possibly be an alternative and here's
one
F6 a kind of a confusing uh unexpected
move can I take on B5 first sir what's
the question can you take where B5 I
cannot take on B5 boy five wow I didn't
even consider that or ECX may I can play
E6 okay G5 is hanging too so you're
opening up the oh yeah no I'm blowing
open the position the point is you're
missing a G2 Bond right I'm missing it
unfortunately I'm missing an H Pawn so I
but the position blowed up but what I
wanted to say was that if you did
capture and captures well I don't know
maybe your king is a little looser than
my king it's a judgment call I'm not
sure I'm right but but I'm just saying
you didn't attack on H3 I can see he did
not take it no I think this is
a monitor but I so he he came up with
something else well let me just refresh
I'm sorry I'm just trying to read it
before that's why he's confused he's
like wait a sec okay
uh sauces can I play B3 that's that's
the question no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
my spidey sense is tingling maybe E6
would then texts
here always you have G6 anyway it's
always the G6 so in this particular case
what black is thinking I'm don't know
I'm that move looks soft
so I can take on actual I can take on B4
then play
beat rate then you're playing suit
Trader
uh and then my idea is like if you play
Knight C3 now Queen H5 G6 Bishop takes
G6 and then because the queen is no
longer protecting Jesus is maybe it was
placed on B4 than B6 actually well but
here just a second you you you you your
Knights are a little bit Loose as a
Goose they are as well right I mean
uh this guy
is literally hanging but it's kind of
hanging there's some loose uh let's just
jump to our Marquee matchup between
Benjamin and dar Rouge because a lot of
developments have happened since we left
it here we were talking about uh this
particular game that you have to play D4
yeah
knight jump to with a Tempo and we knew
this push was coming this move E5 the
question is is how good is it
95 and I think that
um Benjamin made what Maurice would
describe as a grand master decision to
give up this beautiful Bishop on G2
that's a beauty whatever else you think
that's a beautiful Bishop for lonely
night
and he does it with a very specific
purpose and that purpose is he's looking
at blowing open at the position with
either Queen Knight F3 Queen G4 and E6
let's see if this turned out well or not
D3 94
Queen G4 E6
interesting very very double edged and
super sharp okay but it doesn't have
anything concrete then he's just like
results to Bishops right right you're
you're crying are you missing yeah most
probably I'm gonna meet you okay but
wait a minute
um Michael Tall would you say just a
second before we get there there are
some issues that you have to solve issue
number one tal will tell me you don't
understand
no Michael was very sweet he would just
be like are you serious
[Laughter]
and I I know from my beautiful chat
meeting patterns books that night age
so F6 yes F6 and uh I don't see anything
for you yet well I'm I'm fishing
I'm fishing for uh
uh H4 if I remember remember game I
think it was previously yeah we're like
I had that beautiful yeah
we also played H4 H5 and crushed but
this position looks a little bit better
for back because they don't have any
loose like pieces misplaced pieces
double edge we'll keep an eye on that's
a very interesting position absolutely
going back to sassy for a moment before
we'll go to the other uh tournament
before and I think both players are just
kind of confused yeah and also at the
time
only has five minutes and then
nine minutes eight minutes gone down to
eight minutes and only 24 months wow
okay
trouble as Benjamin block and tarish
they have the similar situation as well
wow okay so just a second let me just
Benjamin has how many minutes it's
wealth and then Darius has only 38
seconds so he's
literally making moves on last seconds
right on his you know there is a
technique I have seen like some players
follow when you have like some seconds
you go up to like down to 10 seconds and
then you made a move okay and then it's
40 seconds and they do the like they
repeat the cycle like that which was a
very interesting you it means that you
have 30 seconds to focus and make a move
and then you have to make a move right
immediately then interesting uh
we had our own techniques for the time
controls before the Bobby Fischer bonus
uh was was made again I'm looking at
this position and boy I've got to tell
you if I was in darus's shoes I'd be
really really afraid seriously it's not
a joke one the last time I played Knight
F5 which I'm favorably inclined towards
let me just put another move on the
board just to show you what I think are
the dangers for black in the position
take on F7 Rook takes she also like
white is crushing because of the time
like situation as well right
calculate everything I would love for
you to capture on D4 Knight takes D4
Queen takes D4
we're going to party and we're going to
party I mean and you know there I don't
know
you know I'm I'm seeing a safe
disposition right you grovel
a lot of uh a lot of grand Masters can I
just let you take
can I just let you check on E6 and just
Playbook ae1 and develop my last video
yeah and you know I was kind of hoping
you would do that because guess what I
uh that stupid d-pawn I'm the not going
to take your Rook I'm going to pick up a
key Tempo and well again if you told me
that there was a forcing me you're not
really going to promote I'm going to
take your Rook yes I am you don't know
me I will take your rook and I will
keep an eye on this sorry let's let's
just jump to the other uh tournament
quickly that was the draw I want to go
to our game our Marquee match up because
I'm very curious to see what happened I
was surprised while we were having the
converse conversation with Nico so I was
watching the games and then I was
surprised about G5
I'm surprised by E5 what a remarkable
move maybe sacrifice
yeah
raid I mean it is
I mean can could this really be
considered never mind King C7 is Bishop
B6 we cannot play that's something
yeah this can't be considered bad for
black I mean any trades will be fine and
any time you allow me to trade and play
E5 I was surprised by G5 I I wasn't sure
about G5 H5 and then after that Queen H2
indices
well I'm catching up with the players
what essentially akshot is saying is I
sacrifice upon
but guess what I've got some trying to
massively powerful play for that pawn if
I can drop my Rook to E1 E8
um I don't know if the compensation is
worth a whole Pond yes or the problem is
that you don't have any threats here no
I don't tonight
for the moment you're right but these
positions have a way of blowing if the
king were on A1 I'd much prefer white
because then B1 will be no example
it's a little slow I don't know no I
think E4 is an option E4 is definitely
an option but then I might oops sorry uh
yeah
my intention was just to trade yeah
that's something I was kind of probably
hoping yeah more than enough
condensation but uh to be honest B3 is
not a bad move because the P3 King B2
and suddenly you don't have any mating
ideas I don't have to play King anymore
but like my king is safe
Rook F1 on the board uh again where uh
we're we didn't have enough time to have
a look but Andrew uh Andrew holling won
his game they just Queen's Gambit
accepted remember you were telling you
were teasing me that the Queen's Gambit
exactly it's too uh is too solid let's
see it is too solid but somehow Andrew
always finds a way to like create this
mess right imbalance imbalance there we
go and he's done it he's got a little
bit of a space on the on the queen side
and I'm not a fan of white white has
done to his Bishop I mean if the
Bishop's on G5 we're talking a different
game the bishop something went wrong for
white I need to ask Andrew what did he
prefer where did it go wrong because why
shouldn't lose when you play Queen
I'm like
wow ah oh look at this move and easy two
is coming Knight B2 is on on tap Rook d8
is on tap
you what a cute end yeah very very
impressive uh finish there and 24 musia
service light pieces something went
really very very badly let's take a look
at the game of Armand and Justin
um
first are you still counting I've done
it I did it I did it good you're dead
good job okay
well I think the black has more chances
why and pawn is coiling Eggos
because but you pass Pawn on on A4 is
the most significant at this moment
white doesn't have a pass Pawn so your
feeling is that I mean they're only uh
option to put Knight A2 right like after
if I play A3 you put it which is
precisely why uh Armand played the move
King C2 so his reasoning is is that the
king is a better blockader than the
Knight the King on A2 will be blockading
the pawn yay but the King on A2 will
also be attacking the pawn on A3 whereas
the Knight will be blockading and not
attacking so I can play like this level
Knight A5 Knight C4 okay and I'm a pawn
Grabber so the the two of us are going
to be very happy campers right
A3 and
[Music]
talk
now you gotta go A2 no I can't play even
A2
um well I you could take on this Pawn if
you want but yeah absolutely you could
you can do it the same way no but like
I'm grabbing the G2 phone
I think you're going to get the G2
partner but unfortunately this position
is just a draw it's just a draw I will
probably play uh something
even with uh D5 check and my Pawn will
be compensation enough yeah okay I take
five immediately is not like yeah the
way to go right way to go but like it's
an idea so King A2 makes perfect sense
probably a draw but because we've got so
many exciting uh positions going on
let's take a look at again the Marquee
matcha Rook Cafe Rook F1
right
yes my spidey sense is tingling I don't
see Knight E4
well
you can take on F3
wow even
um
wow what to say uh if I take
I assume the plan is to take
and also Benjamin won his game just now
Darius unfortunately he didn't have any
time let's jump into that game because
uh again that was the key as we as we
described it uh key matchup and look at
this I love uh Bishop D5 by him yeah
what a great role
took and now he played rookie six I was
thinking rookie sex a minute but with
this move Rook E6
hello hello
oh
I think Darius forgot about about Quincy
for totally well you missed
please sign my score sheet I mean queen
D4 that's a terrific move it defends F2
and it introduces Queen h8 mate and that
was it wow Benjamin played a great
that was over that was over quickly uh
let's just jump to the game of
the all Indian Derby if you will between
Generations yeah me too and uh assassin
B3
wow okay he really wanted the two
Bishops and I guess he's saying uh at
the same time
foreign
[Music]
how they think about Chess Rook takes E4
take it away uh begin what do you think
of the position would you like to be
white would you like to be black I would
love to be white because I have a knight
and I can attack the king
that King you see that's a funny thing
that you said about the king because I
always I always carefully weigh uh witch
King is more vulnerable I think that
that's a key element in chess the five
elements King safety being one of them
I'm looking at White's King I'm sorry
it's a little bit more racist there are
many reasons why you would prefer black
right so that's why I prefer white
you're being obstinate rookie too and
then it demands strategically Black's
position is better and then their B3
opponents very strong with two Bishops
if you're going to exchange couple of
pieces it's absolutely winning for black
so this move to my way of thinking to
all generations to all the Boomers
uh I desperately want to play Bishop F5
I desperately want to play the move
Bishop F5 but your knight currently
covers score if I could get in Bishop F5
I would tickle your and I would take the
pawn so this move is saying to me that I
want to play Bishop here Bishop takes
and Bishop F5 so your turn
Bishop C5 Bishop D4 and Bishop F5 is on
my agenda what are you gonna do probably
King H2 and Rook G1 because I need to be
fast so you're thinking that if I go uh
yeah Rook G1 maybe immediately and
I'm
Channel my inner sassy let me try to
find something
[Laughter]
I'm not saying my position is good maybe
E6 let's go baby can I yeah let's do it
I'll fall for it oh
wow my time trouble what is the times
again it looks so can we go back can you
refresh so oh right how do I refresh
just go back and forth sorry it's 40
seconds for four minutes
here we go we think so here it comes
ready once per broadcast these guys are
very good
they found your move baby they're bigger
nice 24 seconds now I mean Bishop C5
when he played the move Rook A2 but he's
hesitating he's not something is
bothering sassy because he's hesitating
to play I think he's kind of afraid like
you know you see ghosts oh absolutely no
question and you want to be safe and he
he thinks Bishop wanna faith is
protecting my king yes and I don't have
any time it's okay let's consolidate and
that's jumping around yeah the play this
movie and most probably now I like even
then I don't have to worry Rook do you
want to meet and I can prepare my Attack
Force somehow he has played the move
Bishop C8 and it's very clear he wants
to play Bishop B7 actually
um because of your Rook G1 idea I do
like the move rookie too so that Rook G1
is not going to cost upon yes sir I do
like my positions right yeah you like
the extra Pawn uh for me the jury was
undecided I I know Anatoly karpov a
classical
world champion love to have his Bishop
on f8 he played the zeitzer variation of
the rui Lopez and he often had his
Bishop on f8 yeah he did he did the move
Bishop C5 and Bishop F5 had my attention
but okay how about White's clock how is
Ari youngster doing 16 years old three
minutes for for grown up 10 months
has only 40 seconds basically he's going
down to 10 seconds and I'm just making a
move again
all right okay we're going to we're
going to keep an eye on this game but uh
we're gonna rotate in Benjamin Mark to
tell us about this extraordinarily uh
nice win today we'll see you later
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
yeah well as we get going here in this
round three Big Ben nice to see you you
look well you think yeah yeah well uh
today
it's all good and this is what we play
for right I mean you know yeah check
mating attacks and uh well uh as we get
you all miked up yeah
not very good are we live right now oh
yeah oh yeah no worries though no
worries
um
we thought that this was the Marquee
matchup of the round that you and
darouch are two of the very strongest
players in the field and uh you played a
Catalan tell us about it go for it yes I
played a cattle in round one against
Nicolas theodoro my teammate at St Louis
University right against that one he
played an early Bishop before check
um
yeah and then eventually two A5 yes so I
had something in mind against uh against
this but Darius surprised me a little
bit with the move Bishop to E7 he has
played this in the past but not so much
recently okay and so I went for this
line with Knight F3 castles in Knight C3
I mean which is already offbeat right
slightly slightly the main move is
castles but Knight C3 definitely also a
main move like Black's main option here
so take on C4 you're 95 and there's
there's Pawn of C5 there's Knight C6
um it gets kind of theoretical and I
kind of understand that Darius didn't
want to go into this unprepared because
white usually gets a slight Edge and
black has to be accurate so right I
understand that he played C6 keeping
more play in a position I castled and
now he played this move A5
and I think I've seen this before I
think my good friend everyone Lami had
this once in in Lycan Zay and I think
what I remembered was that he played 92
and then black played B5 and I think
that Marco madorius mix up because here
if you take the pawn after Queen B6
there's no good way to deal with the
attack on the night like if you go A4
against push base six and black is very
active and if you go Knight C3 here
black takes and of course it makes a big
difference that in the game
so I play B3 and I was expecting him uh
here to play oh yeah he played B6 right
and so I played 92. so it's
contemplating between 92 and 95 but I
thought if I play 95 E4 is not really a
threat because let's go especially
Bishop Basics E4 he has Bishop to B4
attacking my knight oh sorry attacking
my knight and I lost the E4 Pawn Yeah so
not your intention yeah we don't like to
give up
so play 92 right because now you want to
play E4 add some protection to E4 and
yeah I thought he should play someone
like Space six okay I was going to
go E4 right and
um yeah like he can take on C4 for
example I take B5 and I go 93 and 92
make sure it almost The Exchange I do
sack a pawn but I think white should
have pretty good compensation here but
great four yeah two Bishops yeah fair
fair so he surprised me a little bit
with this move B5 in this moment and now
you were thinking hey there's the Irwin
on me game wait a minute you smuggled
the extra move B3
yeah so I wasn't 100 sure but I thought
uh like Aaron's game had this with the
pawn on B2 and so I figured that the
difference is that I can go Bishop to B2
and I think if he does he can of course
play without taking the pawn but I don't
think black should have quite enough
compensation go like there should be two
and out of three and yeah here it was
quite interesting like oh sorry no for
the move so Bishop B2 here he spent over
an hour over an hour yeah like my
goodness okay he has 123 on the clock
here and he went all the way down to 19
minutes
and so yeah I don't know if Queen B4 is
objectively a mistake but I mean you
could argue that he kind of lost the
game here because he got into time
pressure right and here was
contemplating whether I like I want to
go E4 that's my plan but I was kind of
playing Miracle E4 or A3 first but I
think darius's biggest mistake is that
somewhere around here he should have
just accepted a slightly worse position
like out of know if he can take on C4
like
like there's all these lines like this
right something along these lines like
it's not I thought it wasn't that bad I
wasn't I didn't see anything direct okay
for him
uh but he played this move Bishop Basics
I kind of figured that he wanted to
solve his problems concretely and the
thing is that is that in case I go
rookie one here he wants to go Bishop C5
with the idea that if I take he wants to
take here Splat and take and check and I
think it should work out for for black I
mean tf3 Knight G4 I mean he didn't want
to go into this and so if the bishop C5
I'll often have to go Queen F3 to the
fan and then he goes Knight C6 and here
are the differences the tempo is coming
against
and I thought it likes doing okay and
here if I go A3 he can now go to B8
which is why I played A3 earlier so I
played A3 here Queen B6 rookie one
and again I think he should go for
something like
maybe taking here like I don't see
anything direct for white I mean it
feels like white should have a should
have a slight initiative but I don't see
anything direct like I take he takes I
take I mean to be fair this is kind of
unpleasant because now also the rookie
one I have ideas of let's say 94 if he
goes here something like Queen G4 yeah
actually this hello now it might already
be yeah it might have already gone wrong
because I have here with the rookie one
and right it all of a sudden collapses
yeah it just suddenly worked out really
well yeah yeah
um
something around maybe I think it's
G-Force to
or sorry you were saying no no I was
almost on the I was almost on the
pathway of like how bad would it have
been just to sacrifice an exchange
please do me a favor
like okay take on F6 take on F6 take on
A8 take on I've got a pawn I've got the
two Bishops no I don't know uh let's get
to the key right here you made what I
thought was a really
superb decision Bishop on G2 come on how
can you get this beautiful Bishop but it
was the right decision yeah so I also
figure like this feels like the right
move because I have all these ideas of
opening up this diagonals
and the thing is also uh with this like
he's never getting on these on these
light squares because the spawn on D5
this one is not there you know you
always have to be worried that he's all
of a sudden doesn't get something like
this going you know I mean it's just
never never happening and also with
darius's time here I just kind of I just
went for it you know Knight F3 and D4
and like the problem really is after 94
I don't see a move exactly he's
completely stuck and his piece is on the
queen side Queen on A7 Rook on A8 Knight
B8 all sleeping and in the meanwhile you
know E6 uh exactly here he had virtually
no time he's playing on increment and
you played very concretely uh Knight
takes C6 I also was looking at this
position at rookie six and it felt like
gone
right but yeah like rookie six also
feels like a good move but the idea is
kind of that you hope that he takes an
intake of the queen and I feel like I
can take him first and then go rookie
six to make sure that he doesn't have
moves like 1988 yeah exactly and that
was the what we the conclusion we came
to as well so I I thought of Dar like I
think Knight C6 loses on the spot as we
saw in the game I think he has to go F6
which is what begum suggested as well
I mean I was considering that a five and
I'm I mean it's not 100 clear like
it would be nice to play this but I
can't I can't right and like even move
this through there could still be D2
which is annoying else
like I was walking the Knight of five
right Knight C6 I was looking at
um takes right and let's say he takes
nine ideas to go Knight C5 to D7 and
okay this this looks pretty good and he
takes the queen some already I go Knight
B6 right right and this is 97 and it
feels like it should collapse for for
black I was looking at this and some
work yeah still something sex was uh
definitely a culprit and you went on to
win a very nice game uh Benjamin it
feels good you just played a very key
rival you won a nice game how you
feeling I'm feeling great I mean the
last time I played in the classic I won
and I started off pretty badly and now
I'm off to a great start I mean yeah be
Dar is a high seat in the tournament
um and yeah very happy with the way I
managed to pull this one off
congratulations thank you we would like
to see you more I'll try my best to be
back thank you Ben and very have a very
nice uh Victory and I'm just going to go
quickly to the game between panath and
uh sassy because they have reached a
bishops of opposite color
position and one two three four one two
three four five
[Laughter]
but do you need yes yes I missed you uh
I like Sassy's position let's see what
happened hi welcome back by the way
we left it we left it at rookie two yeah
King H2 Bishop C8 rookie two Bishop so
he did end up getting his Bishop on this
nasty diagonal but so far I am
controlling the diagonal like squares so
okay
and this move Rook E6 I think it I think
one of the uh especially in time travel
one of the Cardinal rules in time
trouble
protect
Ing and you know yeah it was aquarium is
doing exactly that's exactly what he is
doing and he secured his king size but
to be honest I like what white is doing
too they are using his time travel to at
least equalize the position
okay so I think black is better you
think
I think white is fighting for advantage
or I wasn't
for Advantage okay okay our generation
is fighting uh we're fighting okay we
just end in a drop like okay we just saw
a very important move Bishop E1 I like
it a lot well in some ways it kind of
clarifies that well white is probably
ready happy to make a draw and then
black has to make two moves
so if he wants to play say if he can
take on F3 and then go for a draw or he
can try Bishop E6 I believe yeah Bishop
E6
back to D5 and I'm assuming the Rook is
going to stay on the second rank just
because I don't want to see what big one
is it SD
he took time pressure you can feel the
time pressure do you get in the time
travel Often by the way I do not I I
like flying faster and we do have by the
way a trade of Queens
uh he took with the queen and queen
takes it you can see how it is he's like
thank God right no I'm not losing I
think he was a little bit worried about
Bishop E6 it feels like I would have
been more worried about Bishop B6
although would you play if you had 20
seconds would you play Bishop E6 or
Ruchi Tech on F3 you know truthfully it
depends upon the tournament situation if
I'm leading the tournament why take a
big risk if I'm trailing of a tournament
yeah I'm gonna play Bishop interesting
my strategy is different oh they agreed
on a draw and they just shook her hands
and perfect and a group is the a group
is actually faster every day they decide
the games
earlier
uh in the a group just to remind
everybody who's joining us late we've
had two decisive games Benjamin Bach won
an attacking
uh good attacking game as Big Nicholas
too Nicholas came in and um well I I
think he played
I want to say a bit too smoothly I
didn't feel the resistance from White in
that game but yeah which was very
surprising
yeah all right and I think we're going
to have a another interview in a very
very short violent we're going to turn
to the other group and I'm going to
leave it I'm going to lead you to it
okay perfect
so
we're gonna have Andrew Hong
very soon
[Music]
thank you
Andrew welcome back to the studio
congrats on your win it's second in a
row how are you feeling about it oh
thank you Mr Craig congratulations
um feeling pretty good uh I think it's
always nice to get a win especially with
the black pieces it's never an easy task
so feeling pretty good so I told Yasser
yesterday that if you play Queen's
gambiter accepted who is Black you
shouldn't win the game
usually it can be a draw if you're hot
like lucky and yes or disagree now you
just beat with black pieces in 24 moves
what do you think what why did wrong or
to get such a disaster
um I think
he he tried to get something interesting
he actually chose the line that um I had
I seem to have no recollection about
which I think it's yeah it looks quite
interesting and then
through the mid game I think he just
kind of flailed about and like didn't
find what to do which I don't blame him
I didn't see exactly what he he should
do either so and it feels very unnatural
for a white to play a rook D1 and then
A4 and like it was it your preparation
and his preparation as well oh no here
we were both on our own um I think you
just wanted to um Force before and carve
out C4 Square for a night but uh I think
it at least in my opinion wasn't that
great because as long as I don't allow
him to play E4 and and activate the C1
Bishop I like I kind of like my position
it seems quite comfortable for black as
well sounds good so you played before 92
it seems like White's position totally
fine here but I wasn't sure about Bishop
D2 Mo
how do you feel about it oh yeah it's
interesting maybe he should play A5 at
some point um
um just to take away this move for me
yeah because then I Bishop Basics
somewhere but on the other hand
um a playing A5 takes away this uh
opportunity for the night so maybe he
was just
um not sure about playing A5 maybe black
can continue like Queen B8 but so yeah I
think it was just like indecisive on his
part so he wasn't really sure what to do
so he just developed the bishop but then
um here I think A5 is good just again
taking away this jump for the night then
um same plan that playing the game Queen
V8 and then I also have this very
annoyingish Basics at some point and
yeah the problem is it's just Bishop on
D2 is unboxing so that's why he had to
play Bishop E1 his idea was to play
Bishop E1 Rook C1 and he felt like most
probably his position was totally fine
but
after this Exchange in Knight C5
I I had a feeling already your positions
better because you're blown MP4 is
better and then he doesn't have any
squares for his Bishop
was it your preparation
no no this is not in preparation but um
it feels like he got tricked and he
didn't know like what what went wrong
um yeah as I said it was just not
completely easy for him to decide on
what to do
um yeah yeah you're right after 95 I
kind of felt that um black should be
quite a bit better
um but it still wasn't easy because
after Bishop CT I've so many options I
can play V3 first I can play E5 I can
also Play Bishop A6 and I'm not sure I
chose the best move in the game actually
I played Bishop A6 but maybe it's worth
including B3 at some point first or even
E5
um and here this is one of those moves I
was calculating mainly because this
queen H5 trick I don't think works
because I've F5
um I'm not super sure five Rook F5
for instance
66.
um but after E5 I wasn't completely sure
because you can play Rook D1 and the
point is that Bishop Basics maybe now he
can play Queen H5
um it's a bit complex or if I play E4
the idea just close all his b system you
might be in time for Knight D2 to
regroup and here I have this trick with
B3
um
because if I uh if Knight takes picture
Basics but I think you can take this way
Queen C2 and I don't have this one if
it's Queen E4 and C7 on bike and play
Vision D3 of Queen C3 I win the piece
but you can sack and I wasn't sure I
thought maybe you can hold it
it feels like your positions yeah that
should be better but yeah I was not sure
but even your Bishop A6 it seems like
it's
uh it's good enough to win the game yeah
Bishop Basics I think here he had to
play with B3 here yeah only move on and
the point is okay if E5 you can probably
just play Rook D5 at least and um six
looks very natural but I
not sure about this queen H5 suddenly
and both are hit after G6 takes
everything you can play Queen B6 here
and still holding on which for text text
takes
on C4 74 to the expert C4
um I mean it's not that easy here reply
so I I think I probably would have just
played something like Rook C8 and I
still have like strong pressure and
still your position is better here as
well so he tried to Rook D1 instead and
do you think you just plundered the pawn
and or he just just wanted to give away
and get some activity here yeah I think
it was half and half he told me after
the game that he sort of forgot this was
possible
um he thought he had something like
trick with a second but it doesn't work
um
also he said he also just didn't want to
want me to play beat three at some point
where his Rook would be trapped in on me
once that's why he put this and okay and
also there's a move like Bishop E4 which
is possible but yeah I think I even I
can even take take Ruth C8 and it's like
still very hard to unpin this Knight
um yeah they have quench before about
five so let's say Rook C1 I can even
play like Rook A7 to C7 and everything's
still pinned so still it feels like your
position is winning there too so he
played Bishop B1 and um like yeah which
is a very bad mama I feel like and then
it was a cute and a queen D5 nice touch
and you won you won the game it feels
like I didn't I didn't understand what
what went wrong for white it seems like
the opening went wrong yeah I'm not sure
what went wrong for what either I
obviously didn't expect to win that's
the magic that the Oscar was talking
about yeah perfect thank you so much for
the interview and good luck with the
rest of the tournament thank you so much
okay let's jump into the next game we
have which is Brandon Jackson versus
Akshay Chandra it's the Team Matchup of
the round today and our a group already
ended the games for today and we have
two more games remaining in B section
and so far it seems like akshat is
winning his game as long as he doesn't
let Knight B6 idea work
exactly I want to see Nike 60. yeah yes
or okay
other than that akshat should be winning
the game and then he has so many checks
it's all around the board exactly one E1
F3 wow four
action who started once again this
remind our viewers with two out of two
he he is on his way to win another game
exactly and that would be the hat trick
three out of three now the question is
where did it happen where did it go
wrong yes please
maybe I should start playing Quincy
[Laughter]
Andrew was saying I don't know what went
wrong and my opponent doesn't know what
went wrong maybe I should start see I if
you saw some of mine let's go back I
would be a terrible influencer oh we
left it about D4
yeah and I thought whoa whoa whoa whoa I
thought black was getting a really
really good
um uh attacking chances and Rook take so
what has he actually sacrificed he
sacrificed two Pawns oh
oh chess stuff especially when your
friends are playing right uh
my our friend Jeremy Selman uh the one
who makes all of those wonderful books
uh he says
chess is hard
and then you die
that's a very depressing life
uh are you a fan of Queen D2 I am not a
fan I feel like he was panicking already
he couldn't believe his eyes that it's
working
somehow no I think he was very scared of
Queen E5 proxy 3.82
Queen E5 Rook C3 and queen A2 Fair
uh the other move that caught my eye as
I was got to this position is Queen
decent
oh
um what's your idea I want to take your
queen but I can take your queen how ah
because you have Bishop E8 preside oh
yes sir precisely I yes I I have missed
the back Rank and just to your point
what you were saying is if I had played
the desirable Queen E5
um Queen A2 yikes I just don't see how
you're protecting this good point okay
five is the only move you have
Queen A1
King G2
okay C2 of course it's an option but
I'm not I'm not happy
um am I winning or not that's the
question that's the question I suspect
you are let's just see what he did
because Queen E5 we can see what scared
him right Queen D2 Queen C4 that was the
move that
uh whoops that that's what happens when
you press the wrong key
just wanted to listen
that you knew that that's an old trick
Rook F4 A6 pause that is a remarkably
restrained quiet move by action he's
he's telling his opponent I can even
play A6 I don't know I mean at this
moment I would be relieved no seriously
I would be relieved to play D5 Queen
takes C5 Queen D4 like uh
like I I feel that I would be well on my
way I don't have any tactics here
probably you do these guys are so tricky
that's why I'm trying to look for taxes
every move I make for example as I
mentioned some of them are my friends
and when I talk to them and I make
positional move there like wait a second
if you do that yeah I'm like oh my God
yeah
uh Brandon did not uh try to return the
material instead he played Rook F1
seeking I suppose to trade Rooks for D3
now
that's what he what we're using probably
well just a second though like as you
said book F1 doesn't look like
look like a move Master Rook D1 is fine
like he's holding against like Rook D
through it in which exact moment uh when
you mentioned D5 yeah he had to go for
it yeah I think this thing having many
materials you can give them away right
that's what we always said the good the
good part about being material ahead is
you can return
why did he give up his Queen I have no
clue so uh question Queenie too oh
correct that's exactly right that's a
check obviously check
so
maybe he was just panicking about the
whole position and was time a factor
probably yes yes but no they were
already weight it moved it was move 40
so time wasn't a factor probably he just
blundered before okay so we're up here
this is no this is just yeah this is
34 right yes here yeah when he played
Rook uh D F1 he had little time already
exactly so okay the player we suspect
that Brandon was playing on increments
at this point but now it's yeah it's
only 30 seconds around 30 seconds
Let me refresh my board sorry
uh yeah and we're we're caught up this
this looks like curtains to be honest
Rook on h8 is placed one
at least you can't lose it yeah there's
nothing like a double attack yes
if they are successful about not losing
C5 Pro I think they have a good chance
of like fighting back but here's the
problem White's King has to protect the
Knight if you go King C4 I'll go check
the King has to move away from the night
and now I'll take upon that's Pawn
number two yeah and then Knight B6 is
not working because C5 is hanging
precisely uh but is that the end of the
story though
Knight B6 is not work yeah I think it's
the end of the story
um
how are you
like are you really Queeny
uh my G6 I don't know if I'm
queening I'm just wondering if my
technique is anything
uh maybe that wasn't my I didn't when I
when I played the move Queen takes G5 I
thought I was taking on C5 and
undermining the Knight maybe it's just
not that completely simple by the way uh
we haven't checked in for a while yeah
should we take a look at yes Armin and
Justin this was where we were tucking
our King to the A2 Square
and I think we were more or less around
these parts and we were looking Prime I
think primarily at night A5 and A3 ideas
uh so 97 King B2
and he's just see he's just smarter than
me he's not giving away his pawn and
putting the Knight on C4 still but the
thing is that he spends so much time and
King on A2 is actually good but if I
manage to play Knight C4 and Rook B2
without giving away my A4 Pawn but I
should win the game well what about that
time out time wait a minute wait a
minute
to play all the most I want I'm the one
attacking your Pawn I'm the one
attacking your Pawn maybe I can play A3
actually the idea is that if you take on
a D5 I can check Rook B2 rookie two and
keeping the knights so you're G2 and H2
pawns are falling as well and you have
more weaknesses than I do
first of all young lady
I have four pawns you have three pawns
so I don't have anymore
NH to pawn too okay yeah I please take
my G2 Pawn I would like to show you
[Laughter]
I understood
um
because my king is so far away my king
was on D3 I would feel I have more
winning chances than I do uh at the
moment with my team way out on A3 I'm a
little bit surprised
I'll just play A3 I believe
just refresh the board sorry
no he did not
shocking it's very shocking right they
don't listen to me that's a good sign
um no seriously I don't like this move I
don't understand the movie so if I take
the pawn what's the trick is he thinking
I don't think you're getting your Rook
into the game because I know hello
by the way isn't this cute that's a very
unusual pattern Knight B2 traps The Rook
just just is a great player I interacted
with him during the Juniors too so it's
I just don't understand my but I just
don't see we missed it we we're missing
something Knight takes A4 and
yes he did Victor course and I had this
great uh expression so you have these uh
in in nature oh my God now he's
oh my gosh she forgot he forgot about
Rook C2 you can I'm sure his facial
expressions so in in nature you have
these animals like a tiger it has fangs
or like a snake at that thing so uh
cortional used to say when you play a
move like Knight takes a four-year
removing a Fang out of the position
you're taking away one of your
opponent's key
um assets Knight takes a41 upon but the
problem is the follow-up Rook C2 Rook is
trapped yeah so in the middle of the
board with me on A3 I guess yeah I think
well I know it wasn't already a great
position for black but it was a try it
was better than this I'm trying to
activate my pieces exactly
um here's one for you though go ahead
tell me how you were activating your
pieces I still I just want to like oh
yeah
exactly Rook C2 no I can play Roxy to
that no I know Knight C4 is possible but
I can foreign
but we have to speak a little softly
just in case they could hear his way
down the street uh the problem is Rook
C2 and Justin
is well I think he yeah if you just
played Rook city of course and he's
gonna play with Devon it's the only move
he has he's so upset right because he
realizes that he's really just given
away and look that
that is completely wrong yeah you can
see he's very upset with himself how do
you deal with that when you when you
make a blender yeah I try to be present
that's the only thing I can do and I
used it what does that mean does it
means that you don't have to start
blaming yourself immediately you can do
that after the game you will have bunch
of times you don't sleep right right but
that's what I learned from my past
mistakes and there were times when I did
minor mistake and my position is
unpleasant and I start blaming it like
putting
um pressure pressure on myself saying
you cannot do that and you shouldn't you
should see such moves and like you are
dumb blah blah exactly right right but
then I found out that sometimes just
keep going and doing your best even
after you did something wrong is the
best choice you can make yeah to stay in
the presence there you there you heard
it uh Rook D1 Knight C5 and we'll see if
Armand can convert but I gotta tell you
it looks really good this is this is
really nice the one problem put the king
anywhere on the king side and they say
it's it's winning put the pawn on E6 I
say it's difficult put the pawn on D5
where it's isolated
you know those Pawn Islands it means
that the night yeah
exactly it's it's a pure suffering for
nothing
um
yeah let's take a look at the current
standings now that we have uh the
history books on group a yeah group a
after three rounds uh Benjamin book is
leading with two and a half points and
he's a solo leader John Burke uh he drew
today and he has two points and in time
for second as a pranath and Nicos
they're tying for a second as well and
others are uh alienism
yeah 50 percent
so far their tournament is going okay
and Darius unfortunately he lost a very
painful game today against Benjamin book
and rodnack is suffering for sure he the
games are not going he can he doesn't
have the resistance and we can see at
the moment and Krishna and Sasha Quran
he had some chances against pranav but
because of the time trouble he had to
force Israel and finally abhimanyu
Mishra he scored his first draw and then
point half a point there we have it
indeed and in the B group and the B
group we have two games remaining
absolutely we have still two games
remaining and Simeon lamassa decided to
have a quick draw against look at this
against
yes and then that's why Andrew Hong with
a win today catch up for the leader and
tying for first action Chandra is still
playing his games against Brandon
Jacobson which is gonna let's determine
many things it's Gonna Change most
probably actually just winning his game
and Alexander Linderman played a quick
draw against Luca Buddhist Salvage and
our Arman is still playing against
Justin Wang and but Suman lost to Andrew
Hong
wow you
you as we see
two two games remaining uh as we get
prepared to sign off I'll just say that
that was scary Benjamin he came in and
he said well one of the last Classics
that I I played in I won so
congratulations and I got off to a
really bad start
hmm
he got off to a really really good start
uh so did you mention it no Benjamin's
feeling good I just we before we do uh
break off uh we got this Brandon uh
Jacobson Jacob's son again game and pack
shot has a moment here that I really
think that would seal the deal he could
play the move Queen check okay the whole
idea is I just want to take this Pawn on
C5 which permanently prevents Knight B6
there goes your counter play Forget
About It game over more or less you're
obliged to play King D4 absolutely I
mean I just don't see it
precisely B2 is falling with check
and remember a moment ago we got into
that position where I sacrificed my
queen now you're pulling up too and now
I got another one in my pocket and I
think uh with that move Queen C2 he'll
seal the deal uh again uh Amman Justin
as we leave it H3 that's a weird move
trying to make a kind of a a chain and I
was about to say if I'm Justin
yeah the moment I played the move Rook
H1 I know you're going to play H4 so
I'll play G5 trying to create a weakness
and trying my absolute best to I think
Justin has more chances right now
because of the H3 move basically
I mean H4 G3 it's so solid and no one
can attack any of your pawns right
here's the here's the real deal that's
going on here though the real deal for
to my way of thinking is this Pawn on D5
is just still a weakness right but I
don't funnily enough uh I find myself
not inclined to the Mover okay too find
myself yeah I'm defined I'm defending F2
but really in my mind's eye I'm playing
potentially for Rook check and if you go
backwards then I go
to attack the weaknesses before black
consolidates
oh no I like how you're like playing and
thinking yeah sir oh what have I done
wrong what have I done wrong something's
happening it's all good everybody thank
you thank you so much for joining us and
uh sharing your day be sure to tell your
friends uh where you're hanging out it
always it's always nice subscribe to the
St Louis chess club in the Scholastic
Center's channel uh so that we can
inform you when we're coming on
our social media platforms as well
exactly and tell them when we're coming
on air in fact we're coming on air every
single day for the next six days at four
Central Central Time Central Europe or
Central
or St Louis time thank you everyone have
a good night thank you good
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited